i did um hentai voice acting with you
right yeah you did yeah that was fun i
think you've done a few things i feel
like that's the only thing i really did
wait hold on do you want to explain that
so so i did this video uh series where i
used to take like notoriously famous
like bad clips and i was like let's see
if like
we
just fix only the voice acting will it
will it like prove that is that the one
i did with you as well i think you've
done it yeah you did as well because a
lot of the time people have this notion
about like shows that uh bad voice
acting and it's like it's it's
definitely the voice acting and it's
like well all right well let's get good
voice actors to do the exact same script
with the same music and all that and
prove that 99 of the times it's like
everything else and then of course if
you throw actors into a bad script or
terrible animation it's gonna it's not
the actor's fault yeah so i wanted to do
that and so i i got a lily to fix some
hentai clips that was fun yeah i liked
that he was like you want to voice some
anti my [ __ ] yeah let's go
like think of how you can kind of expand
it and kind of make it into more content
i feel like at least right now i'm like
there's nothing that i can think of
that's like a great idea yeah
i agree with that i definitely got as
much out of it as i think i i can for
now i don't know also that fixing voice
acting series i could tell
spent like you spent oh those were
i think the biggest thing is just
scheduling that many people in like that
many time zones yeah i remember when i
like used to do a bridge series like it
was fun up until i had to like [ __ ]
schedule recording sessions with
everyone which is just like the biggest
pain in the ass
and i i mean i would do all the voices
if i really felt comfortable but i'm
like i'm british and a lot of the times
it just i don't want to do an american
voice
on command i don't want to
i've done american
movies and stuff as well though okay
we're gonna do scene okay no no no no no
no set up the scene all right hi welcome
to starbucks how can i help you um uh
[Laughter]
oh hi there my name is markiplier
you just give me a coffee
i kind of realized you just did a marker
whenever anyone's like do an american
voice on stream or some [ __ ] or because
i if you give me the line and you give
me like my time to go and read it and
and make sure it sounds american it's
totally fine but on the spot i'm just
like oh hey guys this markiplier here
like that
i'm like what the [ __ ] yeah because you
just have that like familiar like sound
and voice right because like i'm the
same when i try into an american accent
i just turn into like a [ __ ] socal
surfer
so when when you have a british action
right your tongue is kind of like curled
up like this yeah yeah everyone's ever
know yeah so if you want to do it so
that you want to be american same with
australia you just flatten your tongue
and push it back yeah but when i do that
i naturally i sound like markiplier or
like somebody i think it's like the same
like subwoofer yeah
like your voice
you're in the same like submarine yeah
yeah yeah yeah do you want to make more
voice acting content is that where you
feel like your passion is um yeah i
would love more roles but sometimes you
have weeks where you audition and you
get nothing bro the auditioning is the
hardest part it's like soul crushing
how many auditions do you like record in
a week and then how hard you look as you
think because i'm not with like an
agency i freelance for an agency and
sometimes i get auditions from like the
things
but um
when i do get a role it's like christmas
it's like oh my god i'm gonna be happy
for the next year right oh my god
that is so rare you know i wish i could
get more but i know it's competitive a
lot of people yeah yeah
it's really hard even getting the
auditions yeah it's take a long time and
for the as well i mean obviously at
least i'm sure you're the same for me i
don't give a [ __ ] about like the money
part of it of course right voice actors
usually do this because you want to do
it yeah yeah because anime jobs don't
pay
wow it's the bragging right to say i'm
in that yeah because i think yeah anime
pays i think the least of any type of
voice yeah yeah voice acting for money
yeah yeah i mean i mean that's just been
true since the beginning of the like the
anime industry it's it's it's been known
that if you want to get into the voice
acting field for anime it's a hobby job
it's it's like a passion job you know
because you're not going to be able to
sustain yourself and like you know
commercials yeah yeah i think original
animation that's the dream yeah um
that'd be
imagine them cool
stuff to your voice instead of you
trying to fit your lip flaps and then
reading like oh this stuff is better
do you know uh the legends of the
galactic heroes
yes i know that anime yeah so i did a a
voice for one of the episodes recently
and oh my god the lip flaps in that show
were intense yeah yeah i did so i did
another show before that and uh the guy
most of the time was just talking to
himself in his head and i was like this
is [ __ ] easy yeah yeah great yeah
yeah so i didn't have to match anything
but legends of galactic heroes is like
famous for being a very like political
talking anime
i didn't even have that many lines but i
was struggling so hard because they were
like so precise lip flaps and i was like
why would they do this because in
japanese they don't even [ __ ] match
them yeah that i think that's the ironic
thing right yeah the dubbing the dubbing
process they care more about the lip
flaps than the japanese version jeffy's
like oh
he's like it's like you have three
seconds to say like yeah yeah it's so
bizarre how like japanese don't even
give a [ __ ] about trying to match them
yeah it's it's like wha what
in english it's such a big deal if you
look closely there's like a bunch of
scenes where like the voice acting
starts before or after oh yeah yeah
no one cares yeah that's interesting wow
yeah but that's not your star roll
though because you voiced the monkey as
well right i did yeah yeah you want to
show the corpse thing did he give did he
give you that role as well
corpses like messaged me one day and he
was like hey is that the anime where
you're saying
yeah yeah yeah
corpse it's like the danganronpa from
the same as the danganronpa
i saw i saw all my friends part i didn't
know you were a monkey so yeah one of
the parts was like
yeah i was a monkey
that is
why are you looking at me like that when
you're saying it so yeah the cops are
like you want to be a monkey and i was
like that's sick that's [ __ ] yeah so i
went on call and they were like do you
have much voice acting experience i was
like yeah they were like well don't
don't worry about it cause it doesn't
matter anyway you're gonna be a monkey
could you could you demonstrate like
what you did yeah so they were like
could you give me a running monkey sound
like
and i was like what the [ __ ]
how do you not laugh that was the
problem they were like could you do
another one without laughing
because they would be like we want five
seconds of uninterrupted monkey
but you nailed it you know the perfect
let me know if you need a monkey you
watch it afterwards you're like that's
me
i did yeah yeah i was like i'm finally a
monkey in a chair that's always been
like a dream are you the kind of person
who is completely okay hearing your own
voice when you voice act i think when i
it's like an anime or something i'm very
proud i'm like oh my god that's me
that's me yeah oh my god okay i voiced
um in miss nagatoro that was like the
biggest anime i've wasted right i was so
excited to show michael i'm like no it's
it's really cute and wholesome i swear
and then i showed him like an episode
the first episode
she goes hard that first episode what am
i watching
dominate chickens yeah in like the first
episode she makes him she makes like the
main character cry yeah she's like no
but my character's yoshi she's really
cute all my stuff
yeah yeah yeah so many scenes where it
was just like she's just bullying the
[ __ ] out of this
and they're so mean and they're like
yeah like the first two episodes
especially like she does not hold back
at all she
and there is a worrying amount of people
who are really into
yeah i it thought it was like a slice of
life like comfy wholesome from the vibe
i got and then you watched it i'm like
oh i mean it doesn't get wholesome it
does it doesn't get something
it's that initial hump of just like it's
pure like here's like a dummy mummy step
on me energy and then it gets wholesome
afterwards which it's just i didn't know
there could be a show that teeters on
slice of life and psychological horror
because for some people a person like
that is an absolute [ __ ] nightmare
in real life that wouldn't that would
not fall she would not be scary
yeah no it's just a wholesome story
about these four girls i only saw like
pawn of it though like people were just
posting that's because the original
creator is uh
i followed joey so you know i mean so it
was just on your feed it was just on my
scene yeah i would not i mean that's
just like all our feeds now at this
point especially if you follow joey as
well but sometimes some people in my
following like followers list they
retweet literally hentai yeah okay i
don't retweet any of it no i just like
it okay it's okay and it just appears
the problem is okay there's some artists
that i really really like but they also
support other artists and like it's got
it's gone so extreme now that i've
completely forgotten how weird it is to
be scrolling in public on your twitter
timeline and a [ __ ] hentai piece yeah
i'm so scared
i'm browsing but oh big big melons yeah
right there
i tell you what because like living in
japan everyone just like keeps
themselves no it's yeah no it's normal
like when i went back to england on like
a tube and like there was just like on
the metro and like you see a lot of
people around you you feel so [ __ ]
awkward and it reminded me in england
how awkward this is and how not normal
this should be but because living in
japan it's just like it to me it's just
become normal now just to have like
full-on anime titties on my timeline
maybe you should just normalize it be
proud of who you are i mean i could
i mean one day one day we'll normalize
anime titties one day